[Musique]
nous préservons l'ours que nous sommes
laissant une partie de la forêt qui n'est pas
donner de l'oxygène à tout le monde, pas seulement à l'ours
mais c'est évidemment à tous
les gens ont raison donc ça nous remplit
de satisfaction de voir qu'avec le café avec
le projet on s'occupe de l'ours qu'on voit
de quoi
dont beaucoup de gens tombent amoureux
ce
[Musique]
l'idée avec des accords de conservation
est de commencer à générer comme ça
sensibilisation également aux populations du
communauté afin qu'ils puissent comprendre
Quelle est l'importance de l'espèce et
soyez également nos alliés dans
problème de conservation
[Musique]
l'ours andin est une espèce unique
parce qu'il est le dernier représentant de la
grands ours à face courte qui existaient
il y a plusieurs années il y a des milliers d'années
étaient ces ours qui pesaient 5 tonnes
qui chassait de grosses proies et qui
Ils venaient d'Amérique du Nord Amérique du Sud
[Musique]